on est quand même et comme selon m
les échanges ont été vifs entre les
trois chefs au débat économique du
global mail à débat en anglais pour
analyser dans ce deuxième débat la
campagne on retrouve bien sûr daniel à
ottawa tâche à toronto et michel à
montréal
bonsoir à vous trois bonsoir alors la
question que tout le monde se pose après
un débat comme celui là qu'on n'aime pas
toujours poser enfin j'y vais avec vous
daniel qui s'est le plus démarqué
écouter laissez moi vous dire d'abord
que c'est un débat mal foutu beaucoup
trop sujet ou peu tôt pour répondre à
toutes les questions il ya même un
segment sur le carbone du prix du
carbone où je n'ai absolument rien
compris de ce tronçon parlait cela étant
dit à à justin trudeau s'étaient
préparés comme s'ils devaient participer
à un débat de quatre heures il a parlé
tellement bien tu es tellement souvent
que c'en était étourdissant à thomas me
guerre après tu étais le plus incisif
mais temps walter que trudeau
on parle d un extrait sonore qui font le
bonheur des journalistes élus aux radios
mais ça ne dépassait pas souvent les
extraits sonores stephen harper on dit
souvent de lui que ça sa manière forte
si l'économie c'était vrai ce soir il
est resté un peu en retrait mais il
était en pleine possession de tous ses
dossiers et stephen harper ce soir n'a
sûrement pas perdu de points d'accord
tasha ben moi c'est j'ai une impression
un jouet mais c'est trudeau peut-être
parler vite mais
il s'était en effet imposée dans le
débat d'une façon assez importante pas
tout de suite au début mais ensuite par
la suite je pensais qu il avait semblé
prendre beaucoup plus de place que les
deux autres je ne sais pas pourquoi
c'est une question de timing non mais il
a vraiment the boss réitéré son message
que déficit égal investissement il a dit
stop plusieurs plusieurs reprises je
fais l'accord avec son message mais la
façon qu'il a livrée moi je trouvais dû
trouver le meilleur performeur dans le
débat monsieur mulcair était très fort
au début ensuite il semblait un peu
fatigué vers la fin et monsieur harper
oui je suis d'accord il maîtrise ses
dossiers mais il ne s'est pas imposé de
façon décisive je trouvais dans le sens
vraiment frappé un monsieur trudeau
comme j'ai dit était très agressif comme
daniela a dit dans le débat
ouais michel est ce que ça a pu
convaincre les électeurs à ce qu'il ya
des gens qui vont changer d'idée après
avoir vu cette pub à vous pensez vous
ben je pense qu'il est encore un peu tôt
il y en aura plusieurs encore mais il
était important je pense pour surtout
pour monsieur trudeau de conforter
confirmés dont la bonne impression que
les gens ont eu de lui je pense depuis
le début de la campagne et pas de donner
l'impression que le premier des balles
qui avaient eu lieu au mode ou avait été
un peu un coup de chance pour lui
je suis d'accord avec les avec mes deux
collègues ça a vraiment été monsieur
trudeau qui a dominé le débat il est
sorti des blocks comme un sprinter de sa
main était un moment donné on se demande
s est pas forcé un peu sur le café parce
que vraiment il était vraiment speed et
si vous passez l'expression mêmes qui
étaient ils étaient très en forme et il
a je pense qu'il y avait eu un sondage
qui dans le globe justement donné les
résultats ce matin qui démontre que son
engagement de faire des déficits ça
passe bien dans l'opinion publique il ya
49 % des canadiens qui s'en trouve x une
bonne idée et ça je pense ce lui a donné
confiance ils étaient même baveux à
l'occasion quand 4,6 après faut le faire
demander a accusé monsieur dires de
monsieur harper qu'avec des amis comme
lui en alberta ils ont pas besoin
d'ennemis
quand on se souvient de ce que sont la
politique nationale de son père
au milieu des années 70 alors vraiment
il était et il tenait la forme c il a
aussi si vous me permettez je suis une
petite remarque il a aussi cité en tout
début de sa mini son père c'est sûrement
retourner dans sa tombe pour gabon
etes-vous mieux aujourd'hui que vous
l'étiez il ya dix ans sera quoi le sur
harper a répondu très rapidement du tac
au tac
est ce que vous auriez préféré être dans
un autre pays que le canada ces
dernières années écoutez moi je pense
que ça a été un match nul et ça explique
très bien ce débat ce soir qui encore
une fois je trouve qu'il était mal mal
foutu mais ça c'est autre chose mais bon
mais mais mais on comprend beaucoup
mieux pourquoi des trois étoiles yedder
des trois partis sont à 30% ce moment
pourquoi ils sont tous les trois au même
niveau ils ne se sont pas des marques et
moi je trouvais que monsieur l'emploi
est un peu meilleur mais je suis
d'accord avec les deux autres que bon je
sais trudeau a été partout on avait
l'impression qu'il ya juste lui qui
parlait à lille a faim il a eu il a eu
bon de très bons moments mais encore une
fois au centre tant lui que molter que
c'était appris qu'ils avaient préparé de
dire certaines choses un certain moment
à un moment de nous parler de taxe est
un baume au coeur saigne à parler du
programme voici son écran t au sur la
sécurité alors le modérateur août bull
fait le modérateur je m'excuse mais il
faut le dire ne s'est pas imposée dans
le débat
et justement pour leur entrée sur le
sujet et avait plusieurs sorties comme
cela on parlait de plein de choses on a
parlé sur les réfugiés par exemple y
avait eu un échange très musclé et mais
c'est rideau était très bon là dessus
mais c'était rien à faire avec
l'économie alors on voit le sujet un peu
partout
dans les sujets mais là dessus sur les
réfugiés les mesures un peu il y est
allé fort en accusant les deux autres de
vouloir faire rentrer des centaines de
milliers de syriens alors qu'au canada
anglais ont demandé quelque chose comme
45 46 milles en quatre ans c'était ccst
groupe
sauf que là dessus michel suis d'accord
avec toi qui t'es gros mais la tulle
pour limiter à feu est en train de
marquer des points la remontée des
conservateurs ou de le fait qu'ils sont
louis sont en ce moment c'est beaucoup à
cause de ça c'est beaucoup à cause du
niqab est une mesure un peu oui là
exagérait sauf que ils savaient très
bien ce qu'ils faisaient
il a renforcé sa base avec ça il y as 30
% très solide derrière lui à mais bon
c'est un débat télévisé
tout est permis et qui était dit que
c'est sûr aussi pas car on va voir
quelle sera l ce qu'on attend de lui
même la sortie retombées vont surtout
dépendre de ce que les gens vont en dire
demain les commentateurs parce que mon
jeu de a trait au québec je suis
convaincu que programmant qui l'ont
écouté puis même dans le reste du pays
je sais pas dans quelle mesure un six
pack pénètre vraiment tous les foyers
disons que j'avais à défendre son bilan
mais parmi les deux autres qui a su le
mieux incarner le changement imposé sa
vision d'après-vous d'achat mais je
trouve que la vision la petite
différentes mesures un peu certainement
ces messieurs trudeau et c'était les
échanges trouver des échanges entre
monsieur trudeau et monsieur harper
étaient les plus pointus de la soirée ce
qui n'est pas bon pour le npd pour
monsieur mulcair parce qu'effectivement
c'est le positionnement anti un peu qui
compte pour les électeurs qui veulent le
changement de gouvernement et monsieur
rappaz a même fait une admission à un
moment donné que je trouvais étrange le
dire à l'inversé jinguo regrette de
l'économie j'ai pas dit que les choses
vont bien
ce qui est surprenant parce que il dit
que les choses en général vont bien
comparativement aux pays au moins alors
s'il y avait monsieur trudeau a fait
sortir certaines choses de monsieur
rappaz que je m'attendais pas michelle
et moi j'ai trouvé que
monsieur monsieur trudeau évidemment un
carnet beaucoup plus le changement et ce
test est vraiment même quand on
regardait le studio vous aviez monsieur
un peu quand nous on les voyait monsieur
un peu à droite monsieur trudeau à
gauche et monsieur mike est un peu
poignée dans le centre ne sachant pas
trop quelqu'un a dit à un moment donné
que c'est le modérateur qui les écoute
il à votre difficile à votre décision de
ne pas faire de déficit c'est pas un peu
de l'opportunisme et c'est vrai que
venant d'un parti néo-démocrate ça sente
pas très crédible allez me dire qu'elle
monsieur trudeau qui veut faire qu'ils
veulent type il est difficile c'est
assez surprenant aussi tout d'un coup
mais face à monsieur harper il est
évident que le changement l'alternative
la différence elle est beaucoup plus
incarnée par monsieur trudeau ça nous
amène ou pour la suite maintenant parce
que évidemment là on n'a pas assez se
déboîte c'était le dernier débat
entièrement en anglais derrière le
prochain sera ici sur les ondes de radio
canada mais après ça il ya un nom du bob
bilingue le débat manque sur les sur les
questions d'affaires étrangères oui moi
je regarde aller les sondages depuis
quelques semaines tout le monde est à
égalité je veux ici est ce qui va
arriver il va y avoir une étincelle
quelque part que faire en sorte que le
détroit par silva ce départ va se
démarquer et va prendre ses distances
par rapport aux autres ce n'est pas
arrivé ce soir je pars convaincu que ça
va arriver dans les trois débats qui
reste quoique en français la présence
jeu du set
aussi on a changé des choses sont
sûrement way recevant est embarrassante
surtout quand on m'a mulcair un peu pour
pour monsieur harper mais à écouter à
l'événement le plus marquant des
prochains jours c'est demain s'ils
veulent raffut à toronto qui vont
recevoir l'appui de wayne gretzky
à ce prix là je la gère à peine on en
est là la wayne gretzky et pk subban ont
beaucoup plus d'attention que qu'ils en
ont ça tourne en rond un peu on a
l'impression que les gens s'y retrouvent
pas ce soir mais les familles qui se
disait bon mon fils de 15 ans mon fils
de 20 ans la caisse qui va faire lui
quand il va se retrouver sur le marché
du travail qu'est ce qu'on va lui
proposer ce soir beaucoup de réponses
les 30 30 30 % 30 % 30 % c'est vraiment
on n'a jamais vraiment connu une course
aussi serrée d'achat non celle là c'est
vraiment rare
c'est très rare et il ya encore trois
quatre semaines et demie à faire et je
pense que c'est quelque chose que
maintenant on voit qu'on est on est à ce
point là où il faut débloquer cette
situation est ce que ce débat stival
développer ce qu'avoir un momentum dans
une direction ou une autre je pense que
le mieux qu'il ya un momentum que c'est
là que vraiment on va voir cette
situation changer parce que les gens
veulent quelque chose à quoi s'accrocher
et ceux des voleurs les a pas vraiment
donné dans mon opinion grand chose bon
michel
oui mais il ya quand même un certain
nombre d'éléments le monsieur trudeau il
commence à être sûr gens qui présentent
un cadre financier parce que là ils
sortent de choses là mais on peut pas
vérifier jusqu'où ça tient là dans
quelle mesure ça tient vraiment la route
monsieur marocain doit absolument
trouver le moyen de sortir de cette
polarisation là c'est un peu boiteux
comme comparaison me et un peu comme
françois legault québec l'oeil est pris
entre deux deux extrêmes et il y a de la
difficulté à faire passer son message et
les sondages justement mais oui mais il
me donne l'impression lui par rapport
aux deux autres en fait d'être en perte
de vitesse un peu et pour monsieur un
peu il ya une question à la fin qui est
intéressante quand lieu d'écouter
l'heure
vous avez vous le pétrole n'est plus
disons la pierre d'assise l'économie
canadienne à ce que vous avez des
nouvelles idées pour l'économie et je
l'écoutais et j'aurais l'impression
qu'ils étaient en panne d'idées la leur
a vraiment donné faudrait il va falloir
qu'ils donnent l'impression qu'ils aient
pas au bout du rouleau parce que a
vraiment donné monsieur harper devient
un peu comment dire ces solutions ne
semble plus il ne semble plus y croire
vraiment c'est très très redondant
il faut que monsieur à peu trouvé un
moyen de se renouveler un peu alors on
vous retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un autre débat en français celui-là sur
nos ondes ont tout de suite on vous
retrouve tout de suite après la fin de
ce débat qui aura lieu donc jeudi
prochain de 20 heures à 22 heures
merci beaucoup à vous trois d'avoir été
là et dimanche à 11 heures aux coulisses
du pouvoir emmanuel à travers ce soir le
chef du npd thomas mulcair